[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نشاطات مكثفه للقوات
الجويه الامريكيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
مؤخرا بدءا من الحرب على بقايا تنظيم داعش
في سوريا والعراق وصولا للتصدي لتهديدات
التي تشكلها الميليشيات المواليه لايران
منطقه الخليج شهدت تحليق هذه فات به 52
الامريكيه في رساله اعتبرها مراقبون
تحذيرا امريكيا مباشره لايران هذا طبعا
بالاضافه الى مناورات امريكيه اسرائيليه
خدمت نفس الهدف للوقوف على دور القوات
الجويه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط معنا الفريق
اليكسيس جرين كوش قائد القوات الجويه
بالقياده المركزيه الامريكيه اولا همم
يعني همم فريق جرين كوتش برايك ما هو
التهديد الاهم والاكبر الذي يواجه منطقه
الشرق الاوسط في هذه المرحله
هذا
سؤال
من وجهه نظر فان اغلب المشكلات المرتبطه
بانعدام الاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط نبيعه
من دوله واحده وللاسف هذه الدوله هي ايران
ايران لديها مجموعه من الوكلاء والشركاء
في المنطقه وتوفر لهم المساعدات الفتاكه
ويستغلون هذه الشبكه لبث الفوضى عبر منطقه
الشام والخليج العربي ولمهاجمه اغلب
الشركائنا في مجلس التعاون الخليجي للاسف
غالبا ما يكون المصدر هو النظام الايراني
ونشاطاتهم خلال سعيهم ليكون القوه
المهيمنه في المنطقه
اشتركتم مؤخرا في تدريبات جويه مع القوات
الاسرائيليه ويعني وصفها البعض بانها
رساله امريكيه اسرائيليه مباشره لايران
لكن على الجانب الاسرائيلي اسرائيل تؤكد
مرا كان حتميه التوجيه ضربه عسكريه مباشره
لمنشات ايران النوويه انتم في القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه تتفقون مع اسرائيل حول
وجهه النظر هذه ام لا
شك ان البرنامج النووي الايراني يسبب
القلق لكل من يعيش ويعمل في المنطقه
والمهام الموكله اليه هي ضمان الجهوزيه
وتوفير الخيارات المحتمله لردع الايرانيين
والاستجابه لاي تهديد النابع من حصولهم
على سلاح النووي وهذا الامر لا يقلق
امريكا واسرائيل فحسب بل يخلق كل دول
المنطقه واعتقد ان اغلب الشركائنا في
المنطقه يتشاركون وجهه نظر حول ذلك حيث ان
الحصول على سلاح النووي سيكون كارثيا
للمنطقه او سيتسبب في زعزعتها بشكل اكبر
ونحن نعمل بشكل اساسي عبر القنوات
الدبلوماسيه والطرق الاخرى في محاوله لمنع
الايرانيين من الحصول على مثل هذا السلاح
دمج اسرائيل مؤخرا ضمن التحالفات العسكريه
لواشنطن في منطقه الشرق الاوسط كان احد
الادوار على عاتق القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه اين وصلتم في هذا الامر وعلى
الجانب الاخر ما هو ما هي الخطوات التي تم
اتخاذها لتحقيق هذا الدمج على ارض الواقع
سنفور
لدمج اسرائيل في القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه هو الاتفاق الابراهيمي حيث فتح
ابواب التعاوني مع الجيش الاسرائيلي عبر
المنطقه
الاسرائيليون حالهم حالو العديد من الدول
الاخرى لديهم جيش متقدم جدا ويتشاركون
وجهات النظر الخاصه بالتهديدات مع بقيه
شركائنا في منطقه مسؤوليات القياده
المركزيه وانا ارى انه كل ما زاد عدد
الدول في المنطقه التي تخاطب اسرائيل حول
تهديدات المشتركه التي تواجهنا جميعا
وبشكل خاص من ايران اصبح وضعه لمنطقه افضل
وهو مصدر الاستقرار لدمج اسرائيل بشكل
متكامل في الهيكليه الامنيه الموضوعه منذ
سنوات
نمره الجيران كوتش الى اي مدى تعتمدون على
الطائرات المسيره في العمليات التي تنفذها
اا تنفذونها في هذه المنطقه خاصه في هذه
المرحله التي اعلن فيها عن تشكيل الكثير
من القوات وكذلك الوحدات الخاصه لمكافحه
تهريب الاسلحه وتجاره المخدرات ومثل هذه
الامور التي تهدد امن المنطقه بشكل كامل
عددا كبيرا من المسيرات واغلب التي
نستخدمها في عملياتنا هي طائرات نتحكم بها
عن بعد ام كيو تسعه ونحنون نستخدمها لعده
اغراض في المنطقه وكما ذكرت واغلب
استخداماتنا لها خاصه بمكافحه الجماعات
المتطرفه العنيفه وهذه المسيرات تزودنا
بالقدره على مراقبه المناطق التي تشهدون
نشاطات داعش او الجماعات المتطرفه الاخرى
وقدره هذه المسايرات على التحليق فوق تلك
المناطق لفترات طويله
جدا في هذا السياق نحن في القوه الجويه
التاسعه نسعى لتوسيع استخدام التكنولوجيا
غير الماهوله والرقميه فمن ناحيه امن
الحدود ومراقبه نشاطات التهريب فان مثل
هذه المنصات التي تحمل المجسات وبامكانها
تحليق لفترات طويله تمثل اداه مهمه للغايه
فريق جرين كوتشي يعني انت مؤخرا قمت
بزياره عدد من دول المنطقه لكن على
المستوى العسكري كيف تقيم القدرات
الدفاعيه التي تمتلكها دول المنطقه خاصه
في التعامل مع التهديد الذي تشكله
الطائرات المسيره او الصواريخ البالسيه
[موسيقى]
سؤال الممتاز الدول التي تتعامل مع هذه
التهديدات منذ فتره طويله تعلمت كيفيه
التعامل معها ونحن في القوه الجويه
الامريكيه نتعلم منهما واستطيع ان اقول لك
ان شبكه الاكتشاف والقدره على اطلاق
الطائرات المقاتله لاعتراض المسايرات
القادمه واداء قدرات الدفاع الصاروخي لدى
العديد من الدول من شركائنا مدهشه حقا
ولذلك فان تعاون الذي نشهده عبر الحدود
بين الدول المصالح المشتركه ضد هذه
التهديدات التي تقدم بشكل اساسي الى شركاء
ايران مثل الحوثيين في اليمن فهذه
الامكانات واعده جدا لجمع الدولي ذات
المصالح المشتركه لان تعمل جنبا الى جانبه
مع القوه الجويه التاسعه الامريكيه وفيما
بينها من اجل مكافحه هذه التهديدات ولكن
هؤلاء الشركاء يعلموننا اشياء جديده
في كل يوم حول كيفيه مواجهتها هذه
التهديدات
جنرال جرين كوتش مؤخرا بات هناك تعاون
عسكري بين الصين وبعض دول المنطقه هل
لديكم مخاوف في القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه من هذا التعاون او تنامي
التعاون العسكري ما بين الصين وما بين بعض
دول المنطقه
اعتقد ان ايران لديها علاقه صفقات مع هذه
الدول بينما تبني الولايات المتحده شركات
عميقه وطويله قائمه على ما صالحنا
الاستراتيجيه لان الصين لديها مصالح
اقتصاديه ترغب باستغلالها مثل بعض المصادر
الهيدروكربونيه الموجوده
في التوغل في افريقيا او ربما لبيع بعض
معداتهم العسكريه ولا توجد شراكه حقيقيه
واودوا ان اذكره اذا سمحت لي الصينيون
كنديهم حضور في القرن الافريقي منذ فتره
طويله ومع ذلك لاتذكر مره واحده قام فيها
الصينيون باعتراض ايه مساعدات فتاكه تتدفق
من ايران الى احد وكلائهم او قواتهم
الشركه التي تهدد احد دول الخليج في
الصينيون ربما يكونون موجودين هنا الا
انهم ليست لديهم اي رغبه في التعاون او
مشاركه المعلوماتيه فهم فقط يخدمون
المصالح الصينيه خلال وجودهم هنا الجنرال
جرين كويتش ما بين الحين والاخر تظهر بعض
الخلافات او التباينات في المواقف
السياسيه ما بين البيت الابيض والاداره
الامريكيه وبعض دول المنطقه لكن على
المستوى العسكري هل يتاثر التعاون العسكري
ما بين واشنطن وما بين بعض الدول المنطقه
بسبب بعض الخلافات السياسيه
بيننا وبين كل شريك اساسيا في المنطقه
قويه للغايه وبين ما تتقلب العلاقات
السياسيه حسب الاختلافات السياسيه او
التوفق السياسي استطيع ان اؤكد لكم ان
التعاون العسكري يبقى مستقرا ومستمرا
وهناك شركات وصداقات وكل ذلك يوفر
الاستقرار الكبير للمنطقه وانا فخور جدا
بقدرتنا على العمل باستمرار مع شركائنا
على الصعيد العسكري بغض النظر عن ما يجري
في المجالس السياسي فريق اليكسيس جرين
كويتش قائد القوات الجويه بالقياده
المركزيه الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا على وجودك
معنا